I have to say when you said you were 22
that really made me step back I think I
was I think I let that scare me off are
there still any feelings there um I
think it is kind of difficult to wash
back the show and to watch all our
moments from start to finish and
remember really how strong our
relationship was and also see it and
compared to the other relationships with
the other girls I think I always had
doubts in my mind if oh maybe he is like
this with everyone but it's really
obvious watching this season that he
opened up to me in a way that he didn't
with other people and we had a dynamic
that I think was so much more exciting
and I don't know there's something
special that we had between us and so it
is kind of hard to watch back but I
think ultimately it's better for both of
us I don't think I don't think we would
necessarily be compatible in the real
world together sure it sounds like you
maybe have a little bit of like it's
could still work I mean I think he's a
great guy I think though that he made
the decisions that he needed
[Music]